So, of all the stadiums of 2019 Rugby World Cup,...
...this is by far the smallest, with a capacity of 16 odd thousand seats,...
...but by far the most important.
We're here at Kamaishi,...
...the Kamaishi Unosumai Recovery Memorial Stadium.
This stadium is being specifically built to help this city...
...get back on its feet.
And if you look up here,...
...you can actually see all the valleys...
...where the wall of water would have come straight through here.
I can't even picture a 40-meter wall of seawater...
...just rushing straight in through here.
And this is literally where the school used to be,...
...and I ran up to that hill over there to get to safety.
It would have just been terrifying...
...and you can't even imagine the sheer terror of that coming through here.
Seeing the city being rebuilt for the 2019 Rugby World Cup...
...is a truly humbling experience...
...and I can't wait to see the games played here.